we live in an age of remasters and  remakes and the latest game to get the  HD treatment is day of the tentacle and  thanks to digital distribution website  dog we now know when it's coming to PC  day of the tentacle remastered launches  March twenty seconds pre-ordering a  drm-free copy of the game from dog also  Nets you a few bonuses you'll get it for  ten percent off and you'll receive some  wallpapers with your purchase GOG has  exclusivity on day of the tentacle  pre-orders right now so if you're  looking to pick it up you'll get those  bonuses by default stay of the tentacle  remastered is also coming to ps4 and PS  Vita in March but a specific date hasn't  been revealed yet you can stay tuned to  gamespot for whenever that announcement  gets made I'm Tony you can find me on  Twitter at chain gun Pope and yes I do  plan on microwaving that hamster again